this is hot have you ever created a
frittata from scratch
frittata on these cards you'll find a
base frittata recipe to help get you
started
it's up to you to flavor your frittata
in a snap at the end you'll taste test
and rate each other's dish we need four
eggs
Oh
1/4 cup water my gosh honestly I think
this is 1/4 it's so like Oh
I cook boiled eggs if you go to the gym
as a high source of protein okay onions
zucchini prosciutto
do you like pickles I'd love pickles
this would be good with the whatever
this is looking good I'm going in if you
have leftovers you can throw those in
there eggs are a good way to make
everything a meal fries or like
decorations real good no mine looks like
arts and crafts
cook until bottom is set about 8 to 10
minutes you could just watch it all
right
I'm very impressed
thank you this is good this is really
good there's some textures I I don't
know what they are
oh are you kidding this is so good and
it's so easy guys if I have to rate
hurts to be honest guys out of 10 I
would probably rate it an eight
[Music]
preheat the oven to boil royal turn it
on already preheat the oven to the login